Останнім часом з Донбасу майже щодня приходять повідомлення про загиблих.
Українська сторона уже давно застерігає про загрозу нової ескалації.
І скупчення російських військ на кордонах України ці страхи лише посилило.
Зокрема, у прикордонному Харкові. Військових на вулицях міста
помітно побільшало. І загальна атмосфера в місті трохи нагадує
перший ріки війни, коли лінія фронту проходила за 120 кілометрів від Харкова -
між донецьким Слов’янськом і харківським Ізюмом.
А з боку Бєлгорода до Харкова ледь не зайшов "рускій мір".
Звідси до найближчого кордону з Росією в напрямку Бєлгорода
приблизно 20 хвилин на машині. Звідти в 14-тому році, за даними СБУ,
заїхали на автобусах прихильники "руской вєсни" ,
щоб проголосити Харківщину "Харківською народною республікою".
Коли проросійських сепаратистів у квітні 14-того звідси вигнали,
на всіх виїздах з міста було встановлені блок-пости і захисні інженерні споруди.
У 17-тому році майже все це прибрали, бо серйозної загрози зі Сходу, вочевидь, уже не чекали.
Дмитро Олійник був серед тих харків’ян, які в 14-тому році
не дали сепаратистам захопити облдержадміністрацію,
а потім добровільно пішли рити окопи біля російського кордону.
Нинішня ситуація на кордонах, на думку Дмитра, схожа.
Тоді російська армія теж накопчувала війська уздовж кордону з Україною.
Але в самій Україні безпекова ситуація нині інша.
Вже є сформовані правоохоронні органи,
є певна позиція СБУ, очевидна позиція президента.
Я не думаю, що буде таке, що нам доведеться ходити з прапорами
і знову доводити, що Харків - це Україна.
Можуть почати по всьому кордону робити якісь провокації.
На думку Дмитра, за ці сім років суттєво змінилися і самі харків’яни.
У 14-тому під прапори "руского міра" та проросійських сепаратистів
готові були стати значно більше людей. Хоча міське середовище
все ще пронизано духом радянської епохи,
а українська мова у Харкові все ще рідкість,
відвертих прихильників сепаратизму у місті навряд чи знайдеш.
До загрози вторгнення з боку Росії мешканці Харкова ставляться радше скептично.
Ніякої війни не буде! Путін не божевільний, аби її затівати!
Як не божевільний?
- Ні, він не божевільний. Він не зробить цього ніколи! Це чергова лякалка!
- Та він хвора людина! Від нього можна очікувати все, що завгодно!
Ми зі свого балкону, коли вони будуть проїжджати,
будемо кидати все, що завгодно: бомби, гранати!
Політика Путіна незрозмула взагалі. Він не за мир.
Я не знаю, він проти людей взагалі, чи як?
Я сама росіянка. Чесно кажучи, не розумію його політику "дружню",
ми тепер вже не друзі.
Перемир'я не відбулося, яке нам завляли за Мінськими угодами.
А з чим пов’язана ескалація тепер?
Я думаю, Америка там зав'язана. Ну, хочуть залякати.
Це студентське місто. Є багато студентів з цілого світу.
Не думаю, що Росія буде проти цілого світу! І Україна не одна.
Ніхто ніде ніякі війська не концентрує! І не треба нагнітати обстановку!
Звісно, в небезпеці Україна. Треба захищатися!
Що в нас, немає хлопців, які нас можуть захистити? То самі вийдемо!
З моменту окупації Криму і початку війни в Донбасі в усіх регіонах України
почали створювали батальйони територіальної оборони.
Їхнє завдання - у випадку відкритого вторгнення стримувати ворога
на підступах до населених пунктів, взяти під охорону об’єкти
стратегічного значення і інфраструктури до підходу основних збройних сил.
З огляду на пересування російських військ збори територіальної оборони
вже оголосили на Херсонщині. Харківщина не забариться,
каже головний старшина місцевого батальйону тероборони Михайло Соколов.
У Харківській області може бути і через годину, може бути і зараз.
Наші готові! Форма з собою, все з собою.
За дві години ми будемо в пункті призначення і приймемо
службові обов’язки із захисту.
А те, що зараз відбувається, - це брязкання зброєю,
це щоб налякати.
Харків’яни вже не ті, що в 2014 році.
Якщо тоді боялися,і реально боялися, то зараз остраху немає.
Є ще мережі громадських "резервістів". Олександр Горбатенко
до війни займався виробництвом меблів і з військовою справою
взагалі не був знайомий. Спроби перетворити Харків на "ХНР"
у 2014-му спонукали його закинути бізнес
та долучитися до створення громадського резерву захисників,
які в разі потреби можуть прийти на допомогу резервістам тероборони.
Небезпека завжди є. Зараз більше скупчення, і навіть хлопці з фронту
кажуть, що багато техніки. Стільки, скільки не бачили з 2014-го.
Загроза є або це Путін просто намагається залякати
і показати США після того, як його вбивцею назвали,
що я от, мовляв, вам покажу, перевірю, наскільки інші країни
будуть втручатися. Якщо він побачить, що нас ніхто не буде підтримувати,
можливо, піде у наступ.
Резервісти не дуже покладаються на військову підтримку із Заходу.
Кажуть, максимум ті можуть надати зброю, і то не швидко.
Сподіваються, що у місцевої влади вистачить глузду не розігравати
сепаратистську карту. Адже восени у місті пройдуть вибори міського голови.
Після смерті Геннадія Кернеса за крісло мера
хочуть позмагатися проросійські політичні сили на кшталт ОПЗЖ.
Досі ані міська, ані обласна влада ніякого занепокоєння
щодо ситуації з російськими військами на кордоні не висловила.
На запити Deutsche Welle відповіли, що це не їхня компетенція і відіслали до Києва.
Нині головна проблема на порядку денному Харківської мерії -
ситуація з коронавірусом у місті, яка разюче погіршилася останніми тижнями.
Крім того, потенційні наступники Кернеса вже активно включилися
в передвиборчі перегони. Загрози реваншу проросійських сил на виборах
восени місцеві політологи поки не бачать.
Зараз середовище у Харкові є більш проукраїнським, ніж у 2014 році.
Громадянське суспільство більше переконане в тому,
що  незалежність потрібно виборювати.
І  я би сказала, що місцеві еліти
не дуже так орієнтовані на Росію.
За словами експертів, у Харкові, як і в інших прифронтових регіонах,
нині спостерігається ефект звикання до війни.
Насущні проблеми - такі, як ризик захворіти коронавірусом
чи економічні проблеми через пандемію, хвилюють містян наразі куди більше.